and Rafferty is an LAX Los Angeles
International Airport with the statuses
situation there hi Marianne hi Eric well
we're standing in International Arrivals
at LAX you can take a look behind me
we're seeing periodic arrivals of groups
of people that have just travelled back
and just so you know Americans who've
returned from Europe in the past 14 days
are being funneled through 13 different
airports including here at LAX as they
come in and they go through customs
they're then asked a series of health
questions they're also given some
details about the coronavirus any
precautions they need to take symptoms
to look out for then they're sent on
with a directive to go ahead and self
quarantine on their own for a couple of
weeks now President Trump spoke about
the travel ban on Friday during his
emergency declaration of course now the
European ban includes you the UK and
Ireland and potentially could include
domestic air travel as well specifically
from certain areas yes we are and we're
working with the states and we are
considering other restrictions yes now
here at the Tom Bradley terminal LAX
this terminal being the second largest
international terminal in the u.s.
fennels some four point eight million
people through here a year what we've
seen so far today is a lot of empty
areas and that's usually something that
you just don't see here now we've also
seen a lot of people taking precautions
right now as we're speaking you see
people walking by with masks on we've
got a station behind us with hand
sanitizer you know people are just doing
the best they can in trying to get home
we talked to one person who told us
about their particular experience
earlier take a listen you don't worry
about it you know I'm just getting it's
like a little bit of a mess everybody's
freaking out a little bit
I guess it's fear the unknown you know
this this happened before and I think
we're gonna go through so just think
positive and think that it's not gonna
last forever in Eric again everything
that we're seeing here a lot of people
taking precautions I saw a gentleman
right next to us putting his mask on
earlier and he gave me two thumbs up and
kind of shrugged his shoulders like you
know just doing the best they can to try
and get through this we'll bring you
more from here at the Los Angeles
International Airport as these arrivals
come in throughout the day in the
evening Eric
all right Marin glad you've got the the
gloves too and you have the sanitizer
hand sanitizers right behind us so we're
good